Belgium has just suspended the reception of single
men who claim to be seeking asylum.
The measure came into effect immediately and has no expiration date.
Very interesting to Mathieu bocco since the Belgian government explains
its decision by saying it wants to reserve the available places for
women and children who will flock in the coming months.
Question,
what to understand Mathieu of this decision which surprises many Yes,
which surprises many,
because what is Belgium on the scale of Europe today And I will
be my Belgian friends will forgive me.
I hope what I say.
But this is probably the first state to have
given in fundamentally to Islamism.
France through France,
called Belgium.